[Musique]
vous en entendez parler presque tous les
jours ou nouvelles la grande précarité
de ces milliers de demandeurs d'asile
qui entrent au chemin Roxane et ce qu'on
doit faire comme société pour leur
assurer un minimum et l'un des problèmes
qui revient tout le temps c'est la
lenteur de la machine gouvernementale
canadienne pour leur donner un permis de
travail alors le résultat c'est que
plusieurs sont forcés travailler au noir
et pour une rare foi on a recueilli les
témoignages de gens qui ont travaillé
dans des conditions dangereuses et
parfois à la limite de l'exploitation
[Musique]
ils sont partout
dans nos rues ce sont des travailleurs
très motivés dans nos vies mon rêve
c'est de travailler et dans le pays
ils sont prêts à tout faire tout le
temps à toutes les heures et parfois
dans des conditions illégales et
dangereuses
je ne peux pas mourir de faim donc je
dois me chercher quelque chose pour
pouvoir reprendre aux besoins de ma
famille ils sont obligés de travailler
dans le ce que j'appelle dans le noir
eux ce sont les demandeurs d'asile en
théorie ils ont droit de travailler mais
en attendant leur permis de travail ils
vivent dans l'ombre c'est vraiment de
l'esclavage juste pas moderne d'habitude
il se taisent mais pour enquête ils
prennent la parole et raconte leur
désillusion canadienne
je suis migrant même si aujourd'hui je
me sens beaucoup plus québécois et
canadien parce que quand même ma demande
a été approuvé je suis venu par le
chemin de Roxane parce qu'il y a eu le
tweet de Trudeau qui disait que le
Canada est une terre d'accueil oh non ça
c'est du thé mauritanien c'est pour vous
souhaiter la bienvenue en 2018 loin de
sa Mauritanie natale ce diplômé en
langue française s'est lancé un défi
aider les demandeurs d'asile et dénoncer
ce qui les exploitent si on veut changer
les choses en sorte le moment il faut
prendre ses responsabilités et se dire
comment il faut que ça change un certain
moment le silence devient vraiment une
complicité de tout ce qui se passe
cette situation dont parle a dit c'est
celle que vit cette vague historique de
demandeur d'asile qui viennent d'arriver
au Canada et en grande majorité à
Montréal l'an passé près de 40000
personnes ont pris la même route que lui
le chemin Roxane c'est un record mais ce
n'est pas tout en comptant toutes les
entrées possibles notamment par avion ce
sont au total 92000 demandeurs d'asile
qui sont arrivés au Canada
les gens ne sont pas venus ici pour se
cacher normalement dès leur arrivée les
demandeurs d'asile peuvent demander un
permis qui leur permet de travailler
légalement partout dans le pays le
problème c'est que les délais pour
l'obtenir ont explosé quand tu viens et
que tu dois rester 5 6 mots tu ne peux
même pas travailler et que tu veux
travailler parce que tu veux t'intégrer
mais malheureusement
l'administration aujourd'hui toutes ces
pensées sont extrêmement lourdes et les
gens en souffrent
le nombre de demandes combinées au
manque d'agent d'immigration à enrayer
la machine fédérale on est passé de
quelques semaines d'attente avant la
pandémie à plusieurs mois voir un an
mais quoi
on a juste pas le choix et ils sont
obligés quelquefois de faire des choses
qui me qui vont à l'encontre de la loi
ils sont obligés de travailler sous la
table
je m'appelle Henri et je suis arrivé au
Canada le 9 mars 2022 je suis un
mécanicien Henri n'est pas le vrai nom
ce père de famille d'origine haïtienne
comme tous les demandeurs d'asile qu'on
a rencontré il ne veut pas dévoiler son
identité non seulement nous avons
beaucoup passé beaucoup de problèmes
dans la route mais arrivé ici donc on
risque toujours au Canada parce que on
n'a pas de permis de travail donc vous
voyez imaginer que j'arrive depuis les
mars 2022 donc jusqu'à présent je parle
permis de travail je peux pas travailler
en attendant de savoir s'il va obtenir
le statut de réfugiés mais surtout son
permis de travail Henri fait face à des
choix difficiles je paie un logement
1000 dollars et je trouve un aide
sociale environ 1250 dollars vous pensez
qu'il y a quelque chose donc durant une
mois pour manger non oui je suis déjà
obligé de travailler sur la table mais
pas de choix pas de choix ce qui est
important pour nous c'est d'avoir un
permis de travail pour pouvoir
travailler parce que c'était pas votre
objectif de vivre avec de l'aide sociale
non c'est pas mon objectif non c'est pas
mon objectif parce que moi je pourrais
je peux travailler donc je voulais
travailler je vais travailler je vais
travailler
parce que l'important c'est de
travailler parce que on ne peut pas
nourrir donc une maison avec quatre
personnes avec un aide sociale une
dizaine de demandeurs d'asile ont
accepté de nous parler de leur réalité
ils sont tous effrayés mais ils
ressentent le besoin de faire connaître
leurs réalités
très difficiles j'ai travaillé dans le
recyclage même dans les champs
travailler dans le noir c'est difficile
moi et de mon côté je travaille dans le
déménagement mais vraiment hésité parce
que on ne donne pas le droit de
travailler donc sans permettre travail
quand même on le fait parce que on n'a
pas le choix avant de le faire je vais
dire sincèrement je passais beaucoup de
mauvais moments donc les enfants ils
donc ils crient de pour la nourriture
donc je suis obligé de le faire
[Musique]
le procédé est toujours le même que ce
soit le matin la nuit ou durant la
journée on donne rendez-vous à ses
demandeurs d'asile devant une station de
service ou de métro souvent dans le nord
de Montréal
parfois ils ne savent même pas où ils
vont passer la journée avant de monter
dans une voiture une camionnette qui les
emmènera sur leur lieu de travail
c'est dans ces zones on peut vraiment
trouver du travail sous la table il y a
beaucoup d'usines de recyclage et
d'agroalimentaire en général ce sont les
usines qui embauchent beaucoup plus des
gens qui n'ont pas de permis de travail
façon eux ils travaillent avec des
agences tu viens on te donne un badge et
puis voilà c'est fini ces agences c'est
qu'elles font c'est très louche c'est
une exploitation et puis voilà c'est
mafia
on a contacté une agence montréalaise
qui semble cibler les nouveaux arrivants
sur les réseaux sociaux on s'est fait
passer pour un demandeur d'asile en
spécifiant clairement que nous n'avons
pas encore de permis de travail voici ce
que nous a répondu tu es visiteur tu as
fait des démarches pour obtenir un
permis de travail ou d'études quel est
ton statut j'ai demandé la ville en
septembre j'attends mon permis ok passe
au bureau on va examiner tes documents
pour voir sur peu de faire travailler un
autre intermédiaire pour d'autres
entreprises nous a aussi ouvert la porte
bonjour pour l'instant j'ai pas de
travail je vais peut-être en avoir un en
février mars on a tenté notre chance
dans une agence que des demandeurs
d'Asie nous ont recommandés on y allé en
faisant passer pour l'un d'eux sans
aucun rendez-vous et avec une caméra
cachée
[Musique]
rapidement on précise représentants de
cette agence qu'on a aucun permis de
travail pour l'instant et ça n'a pas
l'air de le déranger
une semaine juste avant un message
est-ce qu'il y a des nouvelles pour pour
que ce soit je vais et quand on lui
demande si l'entreprise peut dire non
parce qu'on n'a pas de permis de travail
il nous rassure
tout ce qui l'intéresse c'est de savoir
quelle est la station de métro la plus
proche de notre domicile et il ne donne
aucun détail ni sur le type d'emploi
possible ni sur le salaire
la loi est pourtant claire comme
l'indique Immigration Canada sur son
site il est-il légal de travailler sans
y être autorisé
les entreprises les agences ou les
intermédiaires qui emploient des
personnes sans permis risque qu'une
amende maximale de 50000 dollars et une
peine d'emprisonnement de deux ans les
demandeurs d'asile concernés pourraient
quant à eux être visés par une
interdiction de territoire
malgré ses risques il serait pourtant
nombreux à saisir cette opportunité de
travailler de manière non déclarée je
dirais au moins d'un millier de
personnes qui sont dans cette situation
donc qui sont obligés de travailler
malgré l'absence de son permis valide
parce que leur situation financière les
forces de le faire
cholkyoun documente les abus visant les
demandeurs d'asile depuis plusieurs
années souvent il arrive dans ce lieu de
travail sans savoir ça se trouve
exactement où quel serait leur tâches
exactes à partir de quelle heure jusqu'à
quelle heure donc l'horaire de travail
donc sans les informations de base sur
leurs tâches c'est dans son centre
d'aide aux migrants qu'on rencontre cet
homme d'origine indienne avec l'aide
d'un traducteur
je suis payé 7 dollars de l'heure
je reçois l'argent en cash toutes les
deux semaines je travaille dans des
entrepôts et des fermes en dehors de
Montréal
on est nombreux à ne pas avoir de permis
les gens sont effrayés par la police ils
craignent que quelqu'un appelle
l'immigration et d'être déportés
personne ne dit rien le patron nous dit
je vous donne un job alors si vous
n'êtes pas content vous pouvez partir
des gens sont-ils les traits ils ne sont
pas familiers avec les lois canadiennes
avec les politiques deux demandeurs
d'asile nous ont également donné
rendez-vous dans un centre commercial
pour nous parler de leur expérience dans
une chambre froide de Montréal par peur
de représailles ces personnes n'ont pas
voulu être enregistrées elles viennent
de quitter leur emploi pour une
entreprise qui prépare des repas tout
fait et des sandwichs qui se retrouvent
ensuite dans nos épiceries
elle nous raconte qu'ils étaient une
vingtaine de demandeurs d'asile sans
permis de travail être là-bas parfois
jour et nuit et sans vêtements de
protection pour trier et couper de la
viande on ne pouvait pas se plaindre on
ne pouvait pas dire non c'est ce qui
nous ont confié il était évidemment
payés en liquide mais un jour leurs
revenus a changé leur salaire est passé
de 14 dollars à 11 dollars de l'heure
sous prétexte selon le patron que
d'autres demandeurs d'asile sont prêts à
prendre leur place ces gens deviennent
des poids vraiment faciles pour des
employeurs sans verguant c'est pour
changer les choses que ces migrants ont
exceptionnellement voulu prendre la
parole pasteur dans la vie Willner
caillot se bat alors côté quand ces gens
vous racontent leur histoire on se
demanderait est-ce qu'on est en 2023 au
Québec au Canada
on aurait cru que ces gens d'histoire se
passent ailleurs mais pas sur notre sol
québécois pas intercanadienne où l'on
croit aux humain il ne demande pas la
charité il veut la voir leur permis de
travail c'est tout ce qui demande
au-delà du salaire les demandeurs
d'asile dénoncent aussi leurs conditions
de travail qui mettent parfois leur vie
en danger c'est un bâtiment qui faisait
quelle taille le dernier étage était à 8
mètres se perd de famille Mexique arrivé
l'hiver passé au Canada avec ses 3
enfants nous décrit son expérience comme
peintre de bâtiments malgré la hauteur
il n'avait aucun harnais de sécurité la
nécessité le besoin de travailler a fait
que tu oublies un peu la peur
franchement je voudrais travailler
légalement ce demandeur d'asile africain
a quant à lui vu la mort de près moi
j'ai fait même un accident j'ai cassé
mes deux bras comment vous les avez
cassés vos bras tombés dans un dans une
ville de tri je suis tombé à 8 mètres se
casser ici et ici encore il est deux
malgré nos sollicitations le ministre
fédéral de l'immigration seanfraiseur
n'a pas voulu répondre à nos questions
il nous a plutôt envoyé une réaction
écrite dans laquelle il ne fait aucune
référence au travail au noir c'est une
réalité indéniable que les demandeurs
d'asile vivent des circonstances
extraordinaires nous savons que les
demandeurs d'asile veulent travailler et
contribuer à notre économie le plus
rapidement possible pour les y aider
nous avons adopté de nouvelles mesures
qui permettent une entrée plus rapide
sur le marché du travail canadien et qui
leur permettent de subvenir à leurs
besoins ainsi qu'à ceux de leur famille
plus rapidement
[Musique]
si le gouvernement fédéral promet de
réduire les délais administratifs sur le
terrain les demandeurs d'asile ne voient
pour l'instant aucun changement mais il
garde espoir si vous aviez un message à
faire passer au gouvernement par exemple
ce serait lesquels des noms aider à
avoir un permis de travail sur je
travaille je peux contribuer dans
progrès de ce pays également ils sont
venus ici pour une nouvelle vie donc
c'était pas pour rester dans un coin
caché et marginaliser dans cette société
vous a dit vous espérez que les choses
changeront rapidement pour les
demandeurs d'asile oui j'espère que ça
change vraiment pour eux
c'est même une prière mais pour
l'instant les délais reste long et c'est
vraiment la désillusion il faut vraiment
que ça change l'humanité en a besoin et
vraiment le Canada numérique passe
[Musique]
j'espère que vous avez apprécié les
reportages de ce soir au nom de toute
l'équipe merci beaucoup d'avoir été là
je vous donne rendez-vous la semaine
prochaine pour une autre heure
[Musique]